a desperate dash to save a life pulled
from the debris after a russian missile
strike in the town of vinitza it was
mid-morning when three explosions ripped
through an office building in two
residential blocks the area was packed
the number of dead and injured
significant president vladimir zelinsky
called it an act of terrorism
today russian rockets hit our city
venezia a typical peaceful city cruise
missiles hit civilian buildings
destroyed residential blocks a medical
center and there is a fire
cars were on fire trams this is a
particular criminal act of russian
terror it cannot be done by humans
they're barbarians if the ukrainian
claims are correct and what was fired
were caliber cruise missiles from a
submarine that adds to their allegation
that civilians are being deliberately
targeted because these missiles are
known to be incredibly accurate rarely
straying more than four meters away from
their intended target
the attack came just hours after
ukraine's foreign minister renewed calls
for a special tribunal to investigate
alleged russian war crimes speaking to a
meeting of europe's judicial authorities
dimitro caleb says there should be
coordination
with existing agencies we have heard a
number of reservations since the idea
first floated in the early march
most of them expressed concern that this
effort could replace existing
international courts and tribunals thus
weakening them
i want to clearly reiterate
we do not have any such intention
countries at the ukraine accountability
conference agree the investigation into
the war could take years
but say it's important anyone
responsible for any atrocities must be
held to account russia denies it has
committed war crimes during what it
calls special military operations in
ukraine alan fisher al jazeera kiev